Louisa Ewanitis was just 24 years old, yet her untimely death in 2011 received little more than a brief mention in a local newspaper. Found in a creek, police quickly dismissed any suspicion, despite her being a strong swimmer. This is the story behind Troubled Waters, the latest original podcast from Casefile Presents. Led by seasoned private investigator Julia Robson, the podcast uncovers a gripping narrative full of intrigue. From an international kidnapping and a daring escape, this is like no story you've ever heard before. The entire Troubled Waters series is available now.
路易莎·埃瓦尼蒂斯年仅24岁，然而她在2011年那场不合时宜的死亡，在当地报纸上仅得到了简短的提及。她的尸体在一条小溪中被发现，尽管她是一位游泳健将，警方还是迅速排除了任何疑点。这就是《Troubled Waters》背后的故事，这是Casefile Presents推出的最新原创播客。该播客由经验丰富的私家侦探朱莉娅·罗布森主持，揭开了一个充满阴谋的扣人心弦的故事。从国际绑架到大胆逃脱，这就像你从未听过的任何故事。整个《Troubled Waters》系列现已上线。
Listen to all 10 episodes of Troubled Waters wherever you get your podcasts. Stay tuned to the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. In the early afternoon of Thursday July 2 1970, a family of tourists made their way along the Great Ocean Road in Western Victoria. Known as one of the world's most scenic coastal drives, the 240 kilometre road winds around
在任何你收听播客的地方收听《Troubled Waters》全部10集。请在今天节目的最后收听预告片。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本节目的节目说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。1970年7月2日星期四下午早些时候，一家游客沿着西维多利亚州的大洋路行驶。这条240公里的公路被誉为世界上风景最美的沿海公路之一，蜿蜒穿过
surf beaches, rainforests and looming cliffs, with seaside towns and attractions dotted in between. One of the more iconic stops along the route is the natural limestone formation known as the Twelve Apostles, which lies off the coast of Port Campbell National Park. A three minutes drive west is the Lockard Gorge, named after a shipwreck in 1878 that claimed the lives of 54 of the 56 people aboard. The Lockard Gorge is home to an inlet of protected sandy beach flanked by imposing limestone cliffs. On calmer days the sea is a glassy turquoise blue, but during rough surf waves thread through the gorge making the beach inaccessible. Timber stairs lead up to a
冲浪海滩、雨林和高耸的悬崖，其间点缀着海滨小镇和景点。沿途最具标志性的站点之一是被称为“十二使徒岩”的天然石灰岩地层，它位于坎贝尔港国家公园的海岸外。向西三分钟车程是洛克阿德峡谷，以1878年的一场沉船事故命名，那场事故导致船上56人中有54人丧生。洛克阿德峡谷拥有一个受保护的沙滩入口，两侧是雄伟的石灰岩悬崖。在风平浪静的日子里，海水呈玻璃般的绿松石色，但在汹涌的浪潮中，海浪穿过峡谷，使海滩无法进入。木制楼梯通向一个
rest stop above that contains a car park, walking trails, and a scenic lookout with unimpeded views of the striking coastline. The family of tourists pulled into the car park of the Lockard Gorge and began walking up the slope towards the lookout. As they neared the cliff face, they looked down and noticed there were fresh tyre tracks in the gravel leading away from the car park and towards the cliffs. They followed the tracks and, to their horror, realised that they finished right at the cliff's edge. The tourists scanned the side of the cliff for any sign of a vehicle. Tourists scanned the side of the cliff for any sign of a vehicle. Roughly 25 metres below, a white car teetered on the edge of a rocky ledge with very little
上方的休息站，那里有停车场、步行道和一个可以一览壮丽海岸线的观景台。这家人将车开进了洛克阿德峡谷的停车场，开始沿着斜坡向观景台走去。当他们靠近悬崖面时，他们向下看，注意到砾石上有新鲜的轮胎痕迹，从停车场一直延伸到悬崖边。他们顺着痕迹走去，惊恐地发现痕迹在悬崖边缘戛然而止。游客们扫描了悬崖侧面，寻找车辆的任何迹象。游客们扫描了悬崖侧面，寻找车辆的任何迹象。在大约25米下方，一辆白色汽车摇摇欲坠地停在岩石壁架的边缘，几乎没有什么东西
stopping it from toppling over into the crashing seas below. The tourists used their binoculars to get a better look at the car. They could see it was an older model FE Holden with a crushed bonnet. Debris were scattered around it, and the driver's side door was open over the water below. The tourists wondered if the old car could have been pushed off the cliff for a thrill. Perhaps it had been stolen and dumped. But then they noticed something unsettling. A thick black hose was running from the exhaust pipe over the car's roof and into the driver's side window. The tourists hurried back to their car. That's when they noticed a culvert near the car park had been filled with rocks.
能阻止它坠入下方汹涌的大海。游客们用双筒望远镜仔细观察那辆车。他们看出那是一辆旧款FE霍顿汽车，引擎盖被压扁了。碎片散落在它周围，驾驶座一侧的车门在下方的水面上敞开着。游客们想知道这辆旧车是否是为了寻求刺激而被推下悬崖的。也许它被偷了并被丢弃了。但随后他们注意到了一些令人不安的事情。一根粗大的黑色软管从排气管延伸出来，越过车顶，进入了驾驶座一侧的车窗。游客们匆忙回到他们的车里。就在那时，他们注意到停车场附近的一个涵洞被石头填满了。
The culvert was around one metre wide and 30 centimetres deep and it formed a barrier to prevent cars from getting too close to the cliff. The rocks had been stacked to create a bridge about the same width as a car's wheels. It was clear that whoever had pushed the car over the cliff had gone to considerable effort to do so. The tourists rushed to the nearby township of Port Campbell to report their discovery to a local police officer who accompanied them back to the cliffs of the Lockard Gorge. Taking turns with the binoculars, they tried to see inside the car, but the windows were smeared with salt spray from the sea. With the driver's side door hanging open, the group discussed the possibility that the driver, if there was one, could have fallen into the sea.
涵洞宽约一米，深30厘米，它形成了一道屏障，防止汽车靠悬崖太近。石头被堆叠起来，形成了一座宽度与汽车轮距相当的桥。很明显，无论谁把车推下悬崖，都为此付出了相当大的努力。游客们赶到附近的坎贝尔港镇，向当地一名警官报告了他们的发现，警官陪同他们回到了洛克阿德峡谷的悬崖边。他们轮流使用双筒望远镜，试图看清车内的情况，但车窗上沾满了海水的盐雾。由于驾驶座一侧的车门敞开着，一行人讨论了这样一种可能性：如果车里有人，司机可能已经掉进了海里。
If so, they would have been smashed against the rocks or drowned in the wild sea below, leaving no hope of survival. As far as the officer was concerned, there were only two explanations for the car being at the bottom of the cliff. Either it had been pushed over with no one inside, or it had been intentionally driven over and might contain a body. It had been intentionally driven over and might contain a body. The hose connected to the exhaust coupled with the rock bridge constructed over the culvert indicated a level of deliberation beyond regular vandals and hinted at a possible suicide. If this was the case, it wouldn't be the first in the area. Members of the Port Campbell rescue squad arrived at the Lockard
如果是这样，他们会被撞在岩石上或淹死在下方狂野的大海中，没有生还的希望。在警官看来，关于汽车出现在悬崖底部只有两种解释。要么它是被推下去的，里面没有人；要么它是被故意开下去的，里面可能有一具尸体。它是被故意开下去的，里面可能有一具尸体。连接排气管的软管加上在涵洞上建造的石桥，表明其预谋程度超出了普通破坏者的范围，并暗示了自杀的可能性。如果真是这样，那将不是该地区发生的第一起此类事件。坎贝尔港救援队的成员于下午4点到达了洛克阿德
Gorge at 4pm. Being the middle of winter, they didn't have much time before the sun began to set. With time being of the essence, the task of descending the cliff was assigned to a rescue worker named George who used ropes to carefully scale down the cliff face. When George reached the car, he was amazed that it hadn't toppled into the sea. So precarious was its balance, with a third of its width hanging over the rock ledge, that George thought a gentle push would have sent it over the edge. The front of the car was smashed flat to the windscreen as though it had landed nose first, then bounced back upright. The ground around the car was littered with smashed glass and metal from the crash. Amongst the debris were partially
峡谷。由于正值隆冬，他们在太阳落山前没有多少时间。由于时间紧迫，下降悬崖的任务被分配给了一名名叫乔治的救援人员，他利用绳索小心翼翼地顺着悬崖面下降。当乔治到达车边时，他很惊讶它竟然没有坠入大海。它的平衡非常不稳定，三分之一的车身悬在岩石壁架上，乔治认为轻轻一推就会让它掉下去。车头被压扁，紧贴着挡风玻璃，就像它是车头先着地，然后反弹回直立状态一样。车周围的地面上散落着撞击产生的碎玻璃和金属。碎片中包括部分
eaten apples, broken biscuits, a roll of electrical tape, a butter knife, a plastic slip-on shoe, and some.22 calibre bullets. Up close, George could see that the hose over the exhaust pipe had been fitted snugly, then run diagonally across the car roof and down into the cabin through the driver's side window. The window had been wound up as far as it could go, jamming the hose securely against the door frame, with the remaining gap then stuffed with rags. The hose had also been tied to the roof rack in two places. It was clear to George that whatever had happened, someone had planned this very carefully. that whatever had happened, someone had planned this very carefully. George peered through the salt spray on the rear passenger side window, taking care not
吃剩的苹果、破碎的饼干、一卷电工胶带、一把黄油刀、一只塑料拖鞋和一些.22口径的子弹。近距离观察，乔治可以看到排气管上的软管安装得很紧，然后斜着穿过车顶，通过驾驶座一侧的车窗进入车厢。车窗被摇到了最高处，将软管牢牢地卡在门框上，剩余的缝隙则用碎布塞住。软管还在两个地方被绑在车顶行李架上。乔治很清楚，无论发生了什么，有人对此进行了非常仔细的计划。无论发生了什么，有人对此进行了非常仔细的计划。乔治透过后排乘客侧车窗上的盐雾向内窥视，小心翼翼地不
to upset the car's balance. On the dashboard, both the choke lever and light switches were in the off position, but the keyless ignition switch was on. A rope was tied to the steering wheel which seemed to be attached to the back of the car somehow. The interior was filled with junk through which George caught sight of a toolbox. He reported this over his walkie-talkie and the police officer at the top of the cliff asked if he could retrieve it. George thought his best chance was to try the rear passenger door. When he pulled on the handle, the car rocked, but the door opened, giving George a better look inside.
破坏汽车的平衡。在仪表盘上，阻风门拉杆和灯光开关都处于关闭位置，但无钥匙点火开关处于开启状态。方向盘上系着一根绳子，似乎以某种方式连接到车后部。车内堆满了杂物，乔治从中看到了一个工具箱。他通过对讲机报告了这一点，悬崖顶上的警官问他是否可以取回它。乔治认为他最好的机会是尝试后排乘客门。当他拉动把手时，车身摇晃了一下，但门打开了，让乔治能更清楚地看到里面。
The back bench seat had been removed and the space was filled with an assortment of strange items, including tarpaulins, sheets, electrical tools, a car battery, and battery leads. Most concerning was the presence of several large containers of petrol, meaning the vehicle had been a potential explosive hazard when it tumbled down the cliff. One spark from the battery and the whole car could have been blown to smithereens. One spark from the battery and the whole car could have been blown to smithereens. And there was something else. A distinct odour. George had been in the rescue squad for long enough to be worried by that odour.
后排长椅座位已被拆除，空间里塞满了各种奇怪的物品，包括防水布、床单、电动工具、汽车电池和电池导线。最令人担忧的是存在几个装有汽油的大容器，这意味着车辆在滚下悬崖时是一个潜在的爆炸隐患。电池产生的一点火花就可能让整辆车炸得粉碎。电池产生的一点火花就可能让整辆车炸得粉碎。还有别的东西。一种独特的气味。乔治在救援队待的时间足够长，足以对那种气味感到担忧。
He scanned the insides of the crumpled vehicle and saw what looked like blood on the seat. There was also a coat with blood on it. It was then he noticed a.22 calibre rifle. It was stuck, barrelled down against the clutch pedal. George reached through the smashed windscreen and retrieved the rifle. He opened the breach and found one live round. By this point, Dusk was setting in, and George heard those at the top of the cliff calling him back up. He placed an assortment of items into a cardboard box and centred up the cliff by rope before he was hoisted back up himself. The police organised an overnight watch on the car. They would take steps to secure it in the morning, if it was still there. Back at the Port Campbell police station, officers examined the items George had
他扫描了这辆破损车辆的内部，看到了座位上看起来像血迹的东西。还有一件沾有血迹的外套。就在那时，他注意到了一支.22口径的步枪。它卡在离合器踏板上，枪管朝下。乔治伸手穿过破碎的挡风玻璃，取回了步枪。他打开枪膛，发现了一发实弹。此时，黄昏降临，乔治听到悬崖顶上的人在叫他上去。他把各种物品放进一个纸板箱里，用绳子吊上悬崖，然后自己也被吊了上去。警方组织了对汽车的通宵监视。如果第二天早上车还在那里，他们将采取措施将其固定。回到坎贝尔港警察局，警官们检查了乔治从车里
retrieved from the vehicle. Along with the rifle, toolbox, and blood-stained coat, there were some family photos, old bank books, and a packet of biscuits. There was also what appeared to be a hand-held weapon called a kosh, which consisted of a lead pole encased in rubber. It was clearly home-made. There was also a 10 metre long extension cord and five lengths of electrical cable. Each had a small alligator clip attached to one end and a normal household three pin plug on the other. Police searched the vehicle's license plate number HKU-061 in their databases. plate number HKU-061 in their databases. Records showed that it was registered to 41-year-old Elmer Crawford. His address was listed as Cardinal Road in the outer Melbourne suburb of Glenroy, 240 kilometres northeast of the Lockard Gorge. At 6.20pm, a Glenroy police officer arrived at Alma Crawford's house.
取回的物品。除了步枪、工具箱和沾血的外套外，还有一些家庭照片、旧银行存折和一包饼干。还有一件看起来像是一种叫“kosh”的手持武器，由包裹在橡胶里的铅棒组成。这显然是自制的。还有一根10米长的延长线和五段电缆。每段电缆的一端都连着一个小鳄鱼夹，另一端是一个普通的家用三脚插头。警方在数据库中搜索了车辆的车牌号HKU-061。车牌号HKU-061在他们的数据库中。记录显示，它注册在41岁的埃尔默·克劳福德名下。他的地址列为墨尔本外郊格伦罗伊的红衣主教路，距离洛克阿德峡谷东北240公里。下午6点20分，一名格伦罗伊警官到达了阿尔玛·克劳福德的家。
It was an average single story suburban brick house with a caravan parked on the front lawn. There were no lights on and it didn't look like anyone was home. The officer knocked on the front door, but there was no answer. He peered through the windows and couldn't see anyone inside. Next to the front door was the electrical meter box. The officer opened it and found a loaf of bread and a small jar of coins inside. At the time, bakers delivered bread to customers' homes in the morning, with payment being left out for them.
那是一栋普通的单层郊区砖房，前草坪上停着一辆大篷车。灯没开，看起来家里没人。警官敲了敲前门，但没有人应答。他透过窗户往里看，没看到里面有人。前门旁边是电表箱。警官打开它，在里面发现了一条面包和一个装有硬币的小罐子。当时，面包师会在早上把面包送到顾客家中，付款则留给他们。
The fact that the bread was still there indicated it must have been sitting out all day while the money in the jar was probably change left by the baker. The disc inside the meter box was still. If anyone was at home using electrical appliances it would have been spinning profusely. The officer went across the road and made inquiries with a couple of Elmer's neighbours. He learned that Elmer lived in a house with his 35-year-old wife, Teresa, and their three children, 12-year-old Katherine, 8-year-old James, and 6-year-old Karen. Elmar worked as a telephone mechanic and typically tinkered in his garage and fixed things around the house in his spare time. He often gave the neighbourhood kids rides on his motor scooter around the front lawn
面包还在那里的事实表明它一定放了一整天，而罐子里的钱可能是面包师留下的找零。电表箱里的圆盘是静止的。如果家里有人在使用电器，它应该会飞速旋转。警官穿过马路，向埃尔默的几位邻居打听情况。他了解到埃尔默和35岁的妻子特蕾莎以及他们的三个孩子住在一起，分别是12岁的凯瑟琳、8岁的詹姆斯和6岁的凯伦。埃尔默是一名电话修理工，业余时间通常在车库里摆弄东西，修理家里的物件。他经常让邻居家的孩子们骑着他的摩托车在前草坪上玩耍，
and was always willing to help fix a billy card or bike tyre. Theresa, who was originally from Queensland, was a stay-at-home mum. The three Crawford kids attended school nearby. None of the Crawford's neighbours knew where the family could be, but one thought Elmer was currently on holidays from his job. The officer returned to the local police station to report that no one was home. Given the situation unfolding with the Crawford's smashed and bloodied car, finding the family was paramount. The officer was sent back to the Crawford home with a detective and strict instructions to gain entry via whatever means possible. They were told to be on the lookout for anything that might help
并且总是乐于帮忙修理小推车或自行车轮胎。特蕾莎来自昆士兰州，是一位全职妈妈。三个克劳福德家的孩子在附近上学。克劳福德家的邻居们都不知道这家人可能在哪里，但有一个人认为埃尔默目前正在休假。警官回到当地警察局报告说家里没人。鉴于克劳福德家那辆被撞毁且沾满血迹的汽车所引发的情况，找到这家人至关重要。警官带着一名侦探被派回克劳福德家，并接到严格指示，要通过任何可能的手段进入屋内。他们被告知要留意任何可能有助于
explain the car at the bottom of the cliff. With the knocks on the door still going unanswered, the duo found an unlocked window and the officer climbed inside. He found himself standing in a children's bedroom with two single beds in it. Instead of stopping to look around, he went straight to the front door and let the detective in. The two went back into the bedroom and turned on the lights. Both beds were unmade, and the blankets piled on one of them were heavily stained with blood. There was also a lot of blood near the head of the bed. The officers then made their way to the main bedroom.
解释汽车为何出现在悬崖底部的线索。由于敲门声依然无人应答，两人发现了一扇未锁的窗户，警官爬了进去。他发现自己站在一间有两个单人床的儿童卧室里。他没有停下来四处查看，而是直接走到前门，让侦探进来。两人回到卧室，打开了灯。两张床都没有铺，其中一张床上的毯子被血迹严重污染。床头附近也有很多血迹。警官们随后前往主卧室。
Both the double bed and the floor were splattered with blood. Unwashed dishes sat in the kitchen sink and a box of cereal was left out on a nearby table, alongside a dirty bowl and an opened bottle of milk. This suggested that someone had eaten breakfast there as recently as that morning. A set of car keys also sat on the table. This was of particular interest to the police, given that no keys had been found inside the smashed Holden. A note had been left on the table for the milkman which read, No further deliveries until further notice. Another note had the words Next of Kin written on it,
双人床和地板上都溅满了血迹。厨房水槽里放着没洗的碗碟，附近的桌子上放着一盒麦片，旁边还有一个脏碗和一瓶打开的牛奶。这表明有人在当天早上还在那里吃过早餐。桌子上还放着一串车钥匙。这对警方来说特别重要，因为在被撞毁的霍顿车里没有发现钥匙。桌上给送奶工留了一张字条，上面写着：“除非另行通知，否则停止送货。”另一张字条上写着“近亲”字样，
followed by the name of one of Elmer Crawford's relatives and a town in Ireland, presumably where the relative lived. Between the table and the back door were faint smears of blood. An examination of the Crawford's backyard turned up a length of black rubber hosing similar to the one attached to the family's smashed up car. A large black patch on the grass indicated that a bonfire had recently been burned there. Leading from the back door to the garage was a trail of blood. Two metal rubbish bins sat near the wall of the garage and also had blood stains on the lids. Inside one of the bins was a small length of bloodstained rope.
后面跟着埃尔默·克劳福德的一位亲戚的名字和一个爱尔兰城镇，大概是那位亲戚居住的地方。在桌子和后门之间有淡淡的血迹。对克劳福德家后院的检查发现了一段黑色橡胶软管，类似于系在他们那辆被撞毁的汽车上的那根。草地上的一大块黑色斑点表明那里最近烧过篝火。从后门到车库有一条血迹。两个金属垃圾桶放在车库墙边，盖子上也有血迹。其中一个垃圾桶里有一小段沾血的绳子。
The police entered the garage. Leaning against the wall was the bench seat that had been removed from the holden. There was no sign of a break-in or struggle at the house and nothing appeared to be missing. A wedding ring and engagement ring both sat untouched on the mantle. Based on the amount of blood in the bedrooms, investigators believed that the occupants of the home had been attacked while they were sleeping. The amount of blood indicated they were severely injured or possibly dead. By sunrise the following morning, investigators were relieved to see that the Crawfords Holden had managed to stay in place overnight. After some careful planning, at 9.30am, police and members of Port Campbell Rescue Squad gathered at the top of the Lockard Gorge
警方进入了车库。靠墙放着从霍顿车上拆下来的长椅座位。家里没有闯入或挣扎的迹象，似乎也没有丢失任何东西。结婚戒指和订婚戒指都完好无损地放在壁炉架上。根据卧室里的血量，调查人员认为这家的住户是在睡觉时遭到袭击的。血量表明他们受了重伤或可能已经死亡。第二天日出时，调查人员松了一口气，看到克劳福德家的霍顿车在夜间保持在原位。经过仔细计划，上午9点30分，警方和坎贝尔港救援队的成员聚集在洛克阿德峡谷顶部，
armed with several tractors and heavy chains. They intended to attach the chains to the car and then use the tractors to drag it away from the edge. This time, George scaled the 25-metre cliff face with another member of the rescue squad. After reaching the Holden, the two men carefully opened the back door. In the morning light, they could see blood on the dashboard, the front seat, and the internal roof lining. But they had no time for anything more than a cursory examination. They had to anchor the car to the cliff as a matter of urgency. Once the car was secure, the men opened the back passenger side door again and lifted out the
带着几台拖拉机和沉重的铁链。他们打算把铁链系在车上，然后用拖拉机把它从边缘拖走。这一次，乔治和救援队的另一名成员顺着25米高的悬崖面爬了下去。到达霍顿车后，两人小心翼翼地打开了后门。在晨光中，他们可以看到仪表盘、前座和车顶内衬上有血迹。但他们没有时间进行任何超过粗略检查的工作。他们必须紧急将汽车锚定在悬崖上。一旦汽车固定好，两人再次打开后排乘客侧车门，取出了里面的
tarpaulin inside. It was then that they saw a human foot. They began carefully removing some of the blankets from the rear of the vehicle until they uncovered the body of Theresa Crawford. Entangled around her and wrapped in sheets were the bodies of her three children, Catherine, James and Karen. There was no sign of Elmer. sign of Elmer. The bodies of Theresa, Catherine, James, and Karen were sent up the cliff in stretches and transported for post-mortem examination. Each of them were dressed in pyjamas, supporting the theory that they'd been attacked while
防水布。就在那时，他们看到了一只人的脚。他们开始小心地移开车辆后部的部分毯子，直到发现了特蕾莎·克劳福德的尸体。缠绕在她身边并被床单包裹着的是她三个孩子凯瑟琳、詹姆斯和凯伦的尸体。没有埃尔默的踪迹。没有埃尔默的踪迹。特蕾莎、凯瑟琳、詹姆斯和凯伦的尸体被用担架送上悬崖，并被送去进行尸检。他们每个人都穿着睡衣，这支持了他们是在床上时遭到袭击的理论。每个孩子都有灾难性的头部损伤。八岁的詹姆斯和六岁的凯伦被一击毙命，而十二岁的凯瑟琳受了两次重击，一次在头部侧面，一次在前额中部。克劳福德的车里发现了两把锤子。
they were in bed. Each of the children had catastrophic head injuries. Eight-year-old James and six-year-old Karen had been felled by a single blow, while twelve-year-old Katherine had suffered two, one to the side of her head and one to the middle of her forehead. Two hammers were found in the Crawford's car. Either could have been the murder weapon. were found in the Crawford's car. Either could have been the murder weapon. Theresa Crawford had also suffered a head injury, but hers was less obvious and severe than her children. It looked like it could have been caused by the rubber kosh found in the car wreck. And unlike her children, this head wound hadn't killed Theresa but likely only rendered her unconscious.
任何一把都可能是凶器。任何一把都可能是凶器。特蕾莎·克劳福德也受了头部损伤，但她的伤势不如孩子们明显和严重。看起来它可能是由在车祸现场发现的橡胶“kosh”造成的。与她的孩子们不同，这个头部伤口并没有杀死特蕾莎，可能只是让她失去了知觉。
The pathologist noted burn marks on Theresa's ear as well as the webbing between her thumb and index finger. One detective who was watching the procedure picked up the strange electrical lead that had been found in the Crawfords car, which had an alligator clip at one end and a three-point plug at the other. The alligator clip matched the burn marks on Theresa's ear and thumb, suggesting that she'd been electrocuted by what looked like a kind of homemade torture device. Catherine and James also had the same alligator clip marks, while Karen showed none. It was determined that the children had all been fatally wounded in their sleep, with the oldest two then electrocuted afterwards. Theresa was likely rendered unconscious before being fatally electrocuted.
病理学家注意到特蕾莎的耳朵以及拇指和食指之间的蹼上有烧伤痕迹。一名正在观察检查过程的侦探拿起了在克劳福德车里发现的那根奇怪的电线，它的一端有一个鳄鱼夹，另一端是一个三脚插头。鳄鱼夹与特蕾莎耳朵和拇指上的烧伤痕迹相吻合，这表明她是被一种看起来像是自制酷刑装置的东西电击了。凯瑟琳和詹姆斯也有同样的鳄鱼夹痕迹，而凯伦身上则没有。据确定，孩子们都是在睡梦中受到致命伤的，其中最大的两个随后被电击。特蕾莎很可能在被致命电击前就失去了知觉。
Laid out in the morgue, Theresa's stomach was visibly extended. An examination revealed she was three months pregnant, her fetus an unexpected fifth victim of the deadly attack. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. With no sign of Elmer Crawford and nothing at the family home to suggest that an intruder had entered, this presented only a few possibilities. The first being that Elmer had attacked his family and then driven to the Lockard Gorge to end his own life. While DNA testing didn't exist in 1970, forensic
在停尸房里，特蕾莎的腹部明显隆起。检查显示她怀孕三个月了，胎儿是这场致命袭击中意想不到的第五名受害者。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。由于没有埃尔默·克劳福德的踪迹，家里也没有任何迹象表明有入侵者进入，这只提出了几种可能性。第一种是埃尔默袭击了他的家人，然后开车前往洛克阿德峡谷结束了自己的生命。虽然1970年还没有DNA检测，但对
examination of the Crawford family's smashed up Holden confirmed that the blood found on the front seat, roof lining and dashboard was all Type O blood. Theresa and the children were all Type A. The only member of the family who was Type O was Elmer. The hose attached to the exhaust pipe certainly hinted at suicide. Perhaps Elmer's body had fallen out of the partially opened driver's side door and into the wild sea below. The rescue squad tested all of the doors. Of the four, three could be opened with relative ease. The only door that couldn't be opened beyond 20-30cm was the driver's side door. It took three men to prise it open just so the police
克劳福德家那辆被撞毁的霍顿车的法医检查证实，在前座、车顶内衬和仪表盘上发现的血迹全是O型血。特蕾莎和孩子们全是A型血。家里唯一的O型血成员是埃尔默。连接排气管的软管确实暗示了自杀。也许埃尔默的尸体从半开的驾驶座车门掉出来，落入了下方狂野的大海中。救援队测试了所有的车门。四扇门中，有三扇可以相对容易地打开。唯一不能打开超过20-30厘米的车门是驾驶座一侧的车门。三个人费了很大劲才把它撬开，以便警方
photographer could take photos of the driver's seat, making it unlikely that an adult male had fallen out. The rope that had been tied to the steering wheel went all the way through the vehicle with the other end jammed into the lid of the boot. Near the clutch pedal, where George had extracted the rifle from the day prior, there was a small engineer's hammer and a plastic slip-on shoe. This raised the question of whether the hammer could have been stuck into the shoe and secured in place by the butt of the rifle in order to drive the car over the cliff with nobody behind the wheel. Given the scene was so meticulously staged, investigators were cautious not to jump to conclusions. They'd need to run some tests. A matching make and model of the Holden was taken to Port Campbell. It had been altered to replicate
摄影师可以拍摄驾驶座的照片，这使得成年男性掉出来的可能性很小。系在方向盘上的绳子一直穿过车厢，另一端卡在后备箱盖里。在离合器踏板附近，也就是乔治前一天从那里取出步枪的地方，有一把小型工程师锤和一只塑料拖鞋。这引发了一个问题：锤子是否可能被插进鞋子里，并由步枪枪托固定到位，以便在无人驾驶的情况下将车开下悬崖。鉴于现场布置得如此细致，调查人员谨慎地没有草率下结论。他们需要进行一些测试。一辆同品牌同型号的霍顿车被带到了坎贝尔港。它经过改装，以尽可能复制
the exact condition of the Crawfords vehicle as closely as possible. The back seat was removed, roof racks were attached, and many of the items retrieved from the Crawfords car were placed inside, including the petrol containers which were refilled with water. Four mannequins were stacked in the back seat, their hollow limbs filled with sand to approximate the weight of Theresa, Catherine, James, and Karen. A fifth mannequin was also filled with sand to approximate Elmer Crawford's size and weight and fitted into the driver's seat. A rubber hose was attached to the exhaust pipe and positioned exactly as it had been on the original car, while a rope was attached to the steering wheel and secured by the lid of the boot. Before the car was pushed off the cliff,
克劳福德车辆的确切状况。后座被拆除，安装了车顶行李架，许多从克劳福德车里取回的物品被放进车内，包括重新装满水的汽油容器。四个假人被堆在后座上，它们空心的四肢里装满了沙子，以模拟特蕾莎、凯瑟琳、詹姆斯和凯伦的体重。第五个假人也装满了沙子，以模拟埃尔默·克劳福德的身高和体重，并被安置在驾驶座上。一根橡胶软管连接到排气管上，位置与原车上的完全一样，而一根绳子系在方向盘上并由后备箱盖固定。在汽车被推下悬崖之前，
a cable was secured to the vehicle to ensure that it didn't fall into the ocean. secured to the vehicle to ensure that it didn't fall into the ocean. With police cameras rolling, the test vehicle was driven up the access road and across the culvert on the stone bridge. At the point where the uphill section from the road ceased and the downhill run to the cliff began, the car was brought to a stop. The tyre impressions from the Crawford car were still visible, and the wheels of the test car were aligned with the tracks. It didn't take a lot of effort to push the car towards the cliff. It began to roll under its own momentum, gathering speed as the decline increased. Just seconds before it left the cliff top, the wheels deviated slightly from the original tracks.
一根电缆被固定在车辆上，以确保它不会掉进海里。固定在车辆上，以确保它不会掉进海里。在警方摄像机的拍摄下，测试车辆被开上通道，穿过石桥上的涵洞。在从道路上坡段结束到悬崖下坡段开始的地方，汽车停了下来。克劳福德车留下的轮胎印记仍然清晰可见，测试车的车轮与这些痕迹对齐。将车推向悬崖并不需要太大的力气。它开始在自身动力的作用下滚动，随着坡度的增加，速度越来越快。就在它离开悬崖顶部的前几秒钟，车轮稍微偏离了原来的轨道。
Then the car sailed over the edge of the cliff. Seconds later, the car crashed down onto its front end, just like the Crawford car had. But the test car didn't land flat. It rolled onto its roof after striking the ledge. Nonetheless, police were satisfied with the reenactment because the damage to the test vehicle matched that of the Crawford car. In both cases, the boot was breached and its contents moved forward into the passenger cabin. The toolbox flew forward and damaged the front seat in the same way. The mannequins in the rear of the car remained in their location and the rope tied to the steering
然后汽车飞出了悬崖边缘。几秒钟后，汽车像克劳福德的车一样，车头着地坠毁。但测试车并没有平着落地。它在撞击壁架后翻滚到了车顶上。尽管如此，警方对重演感到满意，因为测试车辆的损坏情况与克劳福德的车相符。在这两种情况下，后备箱都被撞破，里面的东西向前移动到了乘客舱。工具箱飞向前部，以同样的方式损坏了前座。车后部的假人留在了它们的位置，系在方向盘上的绳子
wheel didn't break. The test crash suggested that if anyone had been ejected from the Crawford vehicle on impact, they would have landed on the cliff ledge, not in the ocean. But the test mannequin in the driver's seat wasn't thrown out of the vehicle at all. Instead, it impacted with the dashboard, causing damage consistent with a human body striking a hard surface. No such damage was found in the Crawford car. Detectives were satisfied that there was never a fifth person in the vehicle when it left the cliff top. This lent itself to the second possible scenario.
没有断裂。测试碰撞表明，如果有人在撞击时被从克劳福德车中甩出，他们会落在悬崖壁架上，而不是掉进海里。但驾驶座上的测试假人根本没有被甩出车外。相反，它撞击了仪表盘，造成了与人体撞击坚硬表面相一致的损坏。在克劳福德的车里没有发现这种损坏。侦探们确信，当车辆离开悬崖顶部时，车内绝对没有第五个人。这引出了第二种可能的情况。
Elmer had pushed the car over the cliff. The rope tied to the steering wheel and the rifle wedged near the pedals supported this. If someone had been in the driver's seat, these things wouldn't have been necessary. Elmar had likely injured his hands while filling the culvert near the cliff with rocks. He then touched the inside of the car while shifting it, leaving traces of his blood inside. While investigators were certain Elmer had not gone over the cliff, they wanted to make sure of it. Police divers braced the treacherous waters below as other officers traced the route to Glenroy in case Elmer had tried to
埃尔默把车推下了悬崖。系在方向盘上的绳子和楔在踏板附近的步枪支持了这一点。如果有人坐在驾驶座上，这些东西是不必要的。埃尔默很可能在用石头填补悬崖附近的涵洞时弄伤了自己的手。然后他在移动汽车时触摸了车内，留下了他的血迹。虽然调查人员确信埃尔默没有掉下悬崖，但他们想确认这一点。警方潜水员在下方险恶的水域中搜寻，其他警官则追踪前往格伦罗伊的路线，以防埃尔默试图
make the journey home on foot and perished along the way. A light plane conducted an aerial search of the area while Port Campbell's rugged bushland surroundings were scoured. One detective told the media, "...we want to be absolutely certain that Crawford's body is not lying in the bush or has been washed up along the coastline. If Crawford's body has been washed up, we will find it." After several days of persevering through icy winds and rain, the search turned up nothing, further cementing the belief that Elmer had somehow gotten away. The police turned to the media for help and Elmer's picture was printed on the front pages
徒步回家并在途中丧生。一架轻型飞机对该地区进行了空中搜索，同时坎贝尔港崎岖的灌木丛环境也被彻底搜查。一名侦探告诉媒体：“……我们想绝对确定克劳福德的尸体没有躺在灌木丛中，也没有被冲上海岸线。如果克劳福德的尸体被冲上岸，我们一定会找到它。”在经历了数天的冰冷大风和雨水后，搜索一无所获，这进一步巩固了埃尔默以某种方式逃脱了的信念。警方求助于媒体寻求帮助，埃尔默的照片被印在头版上
of newspapers throughout Australia. Anyone who might have picked up a male hitchhiker with an Irish accent on the night of Wednesday July 1, 1970 or Thursday July 2, was asked to come forward. No one did. Elmer Crawford had been born in Quebec, Canada, before moving to Northern Ireland with his mother when he was two months old. His mother then returned to Canada without him, leaving baby Elmer to be raised by his grandparents in Ireland. He migrated to Australia at the age of 22, where he later met, married and started a family with Theresa. Elmer worked as a telephone mechanic for the Victoria Racing Club. Investigators visited
澳大利亚各地的报纸。任何可能在1970年7月1日星期三晚上或7月2日星期四搭载过一名带有爱尔兰口音的男性搭车客的人，都被要求站出来。没有人这样做。埃尔默·克劳福德出生于加拿大魁北克，两岁时随母亲搬到北爱尔兰。他的母亲随后在没有他的情况下回到了加拿大，把婴儿埃尔默留给了在爱尔兰的祖父母抚养。他在22岁时移民到澳大利亚，后来在那里遇到了特蕾莎，结婚并组建了家庭。埃尔默在维多利亚赛马俱乐部担任电话修理工。调查人员走访了
the club to question Elmer's co-workers. They confirmed what one neighbour had initially told the police, that Elmer had been on holidays for the past two weeks. It was discovered that one of the first things Elmer did upon taking time off was take his wife to a solicitor to make wills in each other's favour. Police found copies of the wheels dated the previous month of June 1970. Then with his three children out of the house at school each day, Elmar had a big clean out. Neighbours saw him burning several large loads of rubbish as well as taking several trips to the tip, sometimes multiple times each day. During each trip, he filled his entire car with junk. Elmer told his neighbours that he planned on using his time off to raise his garage roof so it would fit the family's caravan, which they'd only recently
俱乐部询问埃尔默的同事。他们证实了邻居最初告诉警方的情况，即埃尔默过去两周一直在休假。人们发现，埃尔默休假后做的第一件事就是带妻子去律师那里，立下互为受益人的遗嘱。警方发现了日期为上个月1970年6月的遗嘱副本。然后，随着三个孩子每天都在学校，埃尔默进行了一次大扫除。邻居们看到他烧掉了几大堆垃圾，并多次前往垃圾场，有时每天多次。在每次行程中，他都把整辆车装满了垃圾。埃尔默告诉邻居，他计划利用休假时间抬高车库屋顶，以便能容纳他们最近才
purchased. Some people saw him up on the roof and heard the banging of tools, but it was clear he didn't finish the job in time because the caravan remained parked on the front lawn. Elmer had been due to return to work on Wednesday July 1, the day before his car was found at the bottom of the cliffs. He failed to show and didn't contact his employer or co-workers to explain his absence. That same morning a cosmetic saleswoman named June visited the Crawford home to have a cup of tea with Theresa and leave her with a catalogue. June told the police that she'd visited Theresa at around 10.30am and was surprised to find that six-year-old Karen was home from school. Theresa explained that her daughter had
购买的家庭大篷车。有些人看到他在屋顶上，听到了敲击工具的声音，但很明显他没有及时完成工作，因为大篷车仍然停在前草坪上。埃尔默本应在7月1日星期三（即他的车在悬崖底部被发现的前一天）重返工作岗位。他没有出现，也没有联系雇主或同事解释他的缺席。就在那天早上，一位名叫琼的化妆品推销员拜访了克劳福德家，与特蕾莎喝了杯茶，并给她留下了一本目录。琼告诉警方，她在上午10点30分左右拜访了特蕾莎，惊讶地发现6岁的凯伦没去上学。特蕾莎解释说她的女儿
a toothache. While chatting on the porch, June saw Elmer Crawford walking down the driveway from the back of the house. The two had never met before. June said hello and Ullman nodded but made no effort to start a conversation. June then watched as he began cleaning the inside of the family's holden. She could see that he'd removed the back seat which was leaning against the front of the car. Teresa didn't invite June in like she usually did, and when June offered her a catalogue, Teresa refused to take it, something she'd never done in the past. That afternoon at around four o'clock, Elmer was witnessed loading his car with five gallon drums of petrol. Meanwhile, sisters Catherine and Karen were sighted
牙疼。在门廊聊天时，琼看到埃尔默·克劳福德从房子后面沿着车道走过来。两人以前从未见过面。琼打了招呼，埃尔默点了点头，但没有试图开始谈话。琼随后看着他开始清理家里的霍顿车内部。她可以看到他拆除了后座，后座正靠在车前部。特蕾莎没有像往常那样邀请琼进去，当琼给她一本目录时，特蕾莎拒绝接受，这是她过去从未做过的事。那天下午四点左右，有人目击埃尔默往车里装五加仑装的汽油桶。与此同时，姐妹凯瑟琳和凯伦被目击
walking to the local shops. A Salvation Army hall was located next door to the Crawfords house, and every Wednesday night members of the congregation gathered there for choir practice. On the evening of Wednesday July 1, a congregation member called Malcolm arrived at the hall at 6.30. He noticed that the Crawfords car was parked in their driveway near the front gate. This was unusual because the car was normally parked in the garage or further up the driveway. Malcolm had known Elmer Crawford for nearly eight years, and during that time they'd always had a good relationship. That had changed about eight months prior. Malcolm told police that every Sunday during the Salvation Army church services,
步行去当地商店。救世军大厅位于克劳福德家隔壁，每周三晚上，会众成员都会聚集在那里进行唱诗班练习。7月1日星期三晚上，一位名叫马尔科姆的会众成员于6点30分到达大厅。他注意到克劳福德家的车停在他们前门附近的私人车道上。这很不寻常，因为车通常停在车库里或车道更靠里的地方。马尔科姆认识埃尔默·克劳福德近八年了，在此期间他们一直保持着良好的关系。这种情况在大约八个月前发生了变化。马尔科姆告诉警方，每个星期天在救世军教堂礼拜期间，
Elmer began working around his house, hammering loudly, using noisy power tools and mowing the lawn. Wednesday nights were usually quiet because the Crawford children were typically in bed. But at around 8.30 on the evening of Wednesday July 1, during a break in choir practice, Malcolm and other Salvation Army members heard odd noises coming from the Crawford house. At one point, it sounded like someone was hitting concrete with a pick or a shovel. Doors were slammed and loud footsteps came from the garage, followed by something heavy being dragged along the ground. After some more footsteps and dragging sounds, there was a final dull hollow thud, like a
埃尔默开始在房子周围工作，大声敲打，使用嘈杂的电动工具并修剪草坪。周三晚上通常很安静，因为克劳福德家的孩子们通常都在睡觉。但在7月1日星期三晚上8点30分左右，在唱诗班练习的休息期间，马尔科姆和其他救世军成员听到克劳福德家传来奇怪的声音。有一次，听起来像是有人在用镐或铲子敲击混凝土。门被猛地关上，车库里传来沉重的脚步声，随后有什么沉重的东西被拖过地面。在又一阵脚步声和拖拽声之后，最后传来了一声沉闷的空洞撞击声，就像
car door or boot being slammed shut. By the time choir practice was over, the Crawford's car was no longer parked at the end of the driveway. The drive from Glenroy to Port Campbell took approximately three hours. It was likely that Ulmer had made it to the Lockard Gorge between midnight and 1am. Police estimated that it would have taken at least an hour to build the rock bridge over the culvert and then maybe another half hour to guide the car over the cliff. This meant the earliest Ulmer could have left Port Campbell was around 2 or 3am. But how had he gotten back to Glenroy without a car?
车门或后备箱被猛地关上一样。当唱诗班练习结束时，克劳福德家的车已经不再停在车道尽头了。从格伦罗伊到坎贝尔港的车程大约需要三个小时。埃尔默很可能在午夜到凌晨1点之间到达了洛克阿德峡谷。警方估计，在涵洞上建造石桥至少需要一个小时，然后可能还需要半小时将车引导下悬崖。这意味着埃尔默离开坎贝尔港的最早时间是在凌晨2点或3点左右。但他没有车是怎么回到格伦罗伊的呢？
Police searched the Crawfords garage and found a motor scooter which neighbours said Ulmer rode to work each day. It was therefore theorised that he could have fixed the scooter to the roof racks of the Holden for the trip to Port Campbell, then ridden at home after pushing the car over the cliff. A young girl named Brenda lived seven houses down from the Crawford family. lived seven houses down from the Crawford family. Brenda was a friend of 12-year-old Catherine Crawford. Every weekday morning she walked past the Crawford's house on the way to school to collect Catherine so they could walk to school together. Thursday July 2 was no different, but when Brenda knocked on the door, Elmer Crawford answered and said that Catherine was ill
警方搜查了克劳福德家的车库，发现了一辆摩托车，邻居们说埃尔默每天骑它去上班。因此，有人推测他可能在去坎贝尔港的路上把摩托车固定在霍顿车的车顶行李架上，然后在把车推下悬崖后骑车回家。一个名叫布伦达的年轻女孩住在离克劳福德家七户人家远的地方。住在离克劳福德家七户人家远的地方。布伦达是12岁的凯瑟琳·克劳福德的朋友。每个工作日的早上，她都会在去学校的路上经过克劳福德家，接凯瑟琳，这样他们就可以一起步行去学校。7月2日星期四也不例外，但当布伦达敲门时，埃尔默·克劳福德开了门，说凯瑟琳病了
and wouldn't be going to school that day. The Crawford house was usually full of noise in the morning, but on July 2 it was completely quiet as though nobody else was at home. Elmer didn't close the door right away. Instead, he stood in the doorway watching Brenda walk away in a way she described as creepy. This sighting placed Delmar at home in the hours after his car was dumped. Coupled with the evidence that he had fixed himself breakfast, it seemed he was in no rush to get away. At around six o'clock that night, hours after the Crawford's car was spotted at Lockard Gorge, 16-year-old Alison, not her real name, had been driving down Cardinal Road in Glenroy with her brother. She paid particular attention
那天不会去上学。克劳福德家通常在早上充满了喧闹声，但在7月2日那天，家里却异常安静，仿佛没有人在家一样。埃尔默没有立刻关上门。相反，他站在门口，以一种布伦达形容为“令人毛骨悚然”的方式看着她走远。这一目击事件证实了德尔玛在汽车被丢弃后的几个小时里还在家中。再加上他给自己准备了早餐的证据，看起来他并不急于逃离。那天晚上大约六点钟，在克劳福德家的车被发现停在洛卡德峡谷（Lockard Gorge）的几个小时后，16岁的艾莉森（化名）正和她的兄弟开车经过格伦罗伊（Glenroy）的红衣主教路（Cardinal Road）。她特别留意了
to the house with the caravan in the front yard because a couple of weeks earlier she'd been passing by when she saw a massive fire in the backyard. Allison had initially thought the house was a blaze until she realised whoever lived there must have been burning off rubbish. Passing by again on July 2, Allison saw a man walking down the driveway towards the street. Once he reached the footpath, he looked up and down the street before walking back towards the house. When Alison saw a photo of Elmer Crawford in the newspaper, she immediately recognised him as the man she'd seen in front of the house on Cardinal Road. If her account was correct, it meant Elmer was still at home after the car was discovered, at around the same time the first police officer visited the home.
那栋前院停着大篷车的房子，因为几周前她路过时，曾看到后院燃起熊熊大火。艾莉森起初以为房子着火了，后来才意识到住在那儿的人一定是在焚烧垃圾。7月2日再次路过时，艾莉森看到一个男人正沿着车道走向街道。当他走到人行道上时，他向街道两头张望了一下，然后又走回了房子。当艾莉森在报纸上看到埃尔默·克劳福德的照片时，她立刻认出他就是她在红衣主教路那栋房子前看到的男人。如果她的描述属实，这意味着在汽车被发现后，埃尔默仍然待在家里，而当时大约正是第一位警察上门走访的时间。
When police returned to the Crawford home at around 10.30pm and broke in, they noticed some small patches of the carpet in one of the bedrooms were still wet. On the coffee table in the lounge room was a clear bottle of upholstery cleaning fluid. The fluid inside was frothy on the surface as though it had only been used within the past few hours. Its cap had an inbuilt brush and there were fibres caught in it that were similar to the carpet fibres. It looked like someone had tried to clean up the blood stains but given up in the process. Given that the clean up looked as though it had been abandoned relatively recently, it struck investigators that Elmer could have been cleaning up the crime scene when the first officer knocked at 6.20pm.
当警察在晚上10点30分左右回到克劳福德家并破门而入时，他们注意到其中一间卧室的地毯上有几处小块区域仍然是湿的。客厅的咖啡桌上放着一瓶透明的室内装潢清洁剂。瓶里的液体表面有泡沫，看起来就像是过去几个小时内刚使用过一样。瓶盖上有一个内置刷子，上面粘着的纤维与地毯纤维相似。看起来有人试图清理血迹，但在过程中放弃了。鉴于清理工作看起来像是最近才被搁置的，调查人员认为，当第一位警官在晚上6点20分敲门时，埃尔默可能正在清理犯罪现场。
Perhaps he had thought he'd gotten away with his crime only to catch a glimpse of the officer and realise it had all gone awry. If this was the case, this meant that Elmer had vanished sometime between the police's first visit at 6.20 and their return to the house at 10.30. Elmer's motor scooter was still in the garage along with an adult bicycle. This raised the question of how he fled the house in Cardinal Road. There had been no confirmed sightings of Elmar since he left home for good. Had he simply walked away, or taken a bus, or had someone picked him up? Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors.
也许他以为自己已经逃脱了罪责，却瞥见了警察，意识到一切都搞砸了。如果真是这样，这意味着埃尔默在警察第一次于6点20分到访和他们10点30分返回房子之间的某个时间点消失了。埃尔默的摩托车和一辆成人自行车仍然在车库里。这引发了一个问题：他是如何逃离红衣主教路的房子的？自埃尔默离家出走后，再也没有关于他的确切目击报告。他是步行离开的，还是坐了公交车，又或者是有人接走了他？Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。
Have you ever stopped to think about how much you spend on subscriptions each month? The answer is likely more than you realise. Over 74% of people have subscriptions they've forgotten about. I know I did, like paying for multiple fitness programs I no longer used. Thankfully, Rocket Money helped me stop wasting money on the ones I'd forgotten about. With Rocket Money, I can easily track my expenses and view all my subscriptions in one spot. If there's a subscription I no longer need, Rocket Money makes it easy to cancel with just a few taps. The dashboard shows this month's spending compared to last month's, so I can easily see my spending habits.
你有没有停下来想过你每个月在订阅服务上花了多少钱？答案很可能比你意识到的要多。超过74%的人都有他们已经忘记的订阅服务。我知道我就是这样，比如为多个我不再使用的健身项目付费。值得庆幸的是，Rocket Money帮助我停止在那些我早已遗忘的项目上浪费金钱。通过Rocket Money，我可以轻松追踪我的开支，并在一个地方查看我所有的订阅。如果我不再需要某个订阅，Rocket Money只需轻点几下就能轻松取消。仪表板显示了本月的支出与上个月的对比，所以我可以轻松查看我的消费习惯。
Plus, they help me create a custom budget to keep my spending on track. Over 5 million users have saved a total of $500 million in cancelled subscriptions, saving members up to $740 a year when using all of the app's features. So stop wasting money on things you don't use. Cancel your unwanted subscriptions by going to rocketmoney.com slash casefile. That's rocketmoney.com slash casefile. Rocketmoney.com slash case file. Rocketmoney.com slash case file.
此外，他们还帮助我制定个性化预算，以保持我的支出在正轨上。超过500万用户通过取消订阅总共节省了5亿美元，在使用该应用程序的所有功能时，会员每年最多可节省740美元。所以，别再把钱浪费在你不用东西上了。前往rocketmoney.com斜杠casefile取消你不需要的订阅。网址是rocketmoney.com斜杠casefile。Rocketmoney.com斜杠casefile。Rocketmoney.com斜杠casefile。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Whatever the case, investigators were bewildered as to why Elmer made the drastic decision to wipe out his family in the first place. By all accounts, the Crawfords were a typical friendly family. No one recalled ever hearing arguments coming from their house, nor did Theresa ever complain about her husband. When the Crawfords socialised with neighbours, Elmer was said to be affectionate towards his wife and children, who were also described as being well behaved. Elmer earned nearly $5,000 a year, or $70,000 in today's money.
感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。无论如何，调查人员对埃尔默当初为何做出消灭全家的极端决定感到困惑。据各方描述，克劳福德一家是典型的友好家庭。没有人记得曾听到过他们家传出争吵声，特蕾莎也从未抱怨过她的丈夫。当克劳福德一家与邻居社交时，据说埃尔默对妻子和孩子表现得很亲昵，孩子们也被描述为举止端庄。埃尔默年收入近5000美元，相当于今天的7万美元。
A search of the Crawford' bank accounts revealed they had a further three thousand dollars in savings and another three thousand in government bonds. Their house was almost paid off and they owned three blocks of land in Queensland as well as their caravan and car. For a single income family they were very well off, more so than the average. Whatever motive Elmer Crawford might have had to kill his family, it didn't appear to be financial. A woman named Jennifer who lived up the street regarded Teresa Crawford as a good friend. She told the police that while she knew Teresa very well, she knew next to nothing about Elmer and had barely ever spoken to him. Jennifer described the Crawfords as a happy family.
对克劳福德银行账户的搜索显示，他们还有3000美元的储蓄和3000美元的政府债券。他们的房子几乎已经付清，他们在昆士兰州拥有三块土地，还有他们的大篷车和汽车。对于一个单收入家庭来说，他们非常富裕，比平均水平要好得多。无论埃尔默·克劳福德杀害家人的动机是什么，看起来似乎与经济无关。一位住在街上的名叫詹妮弗的女性将特蕾莎·克劳福德视为好朋友。她告诉警察，虽然她非常了解特蕾莎，但她对埃尔默几乎一无所知，也几乎没和他说过话。詹妮弗形容克劳福德一家是一个幸福的家庭。
The last time she'd seen them all was on the night of Tuesday June 30. Jennifer visited the Crawford home and was told that Elmer had spent the day taking rubbish to the tip. When Jennifer asked if Elmer had gone back to work yet, Theresa responded, No, isn't it awful? He should have gone back a couple of days ago. I think he will be going back soon. While the two women spoke at the front door, Jennifer saw Elmer back the car out of the driveway and drive off.
她最后一次见到他们全家是在6月30日星期二的晚上。詹妮弗拜访了克劳福德家，被告知埃尔默那天一直在把垃圾运往垃圾场。当詹妮弗问埃尔默是否已经回去上班时，特蕾莎回答说：“没有，这不是很糟糕吗？他本该几天前就回去的。我想他很快就会回去的。”当两个女人在门口交谈时，詹妮弗看到埃尔默把车从车道上倒出来并开车离开了。
The detectives asked Jennifer if she knew Theresa was expecting a baby. Jennifer said yes and recalled that Theresa seemed very pleased about it. When Jennifer had asked what Elmar thought, Theresa responded, Oh, well, you know Elmar. During the search of the Crawford home, police had found a newspaper clipping on the kitchen table that had them questioning whether the news of the pregnancy was welcome. Taken from the age, the clipping was titled A Mother's Agony and featured an emotional letter to the editor in response to an article the previous week about abortion reform. The letter described one mother's experience as she had unsuccessfully tried to terminate her
侦探们问詹妮弗是否知道特蕾莎怀孕了。詹妮弗说知道，并回忆说特蕾莎对此似乎非常高兴。当詹妮弗问埃尔默怎么想时，特蕾莎回答说：“哦，好吧，你知道埃尔默的。”在搜查克劳福德家时，警察在餐桌上发现了一张报纸剪报，这让他们怀疑这个怀孕的消息是否受欢迎。这张剪报摘自《时代报》（The Age），标题为《一位母亲的痛苦》，刊登了一封给编辑的情感信件，以回应前一周关于堕胎改革的文章。这封信描述了一位母亲在试图终止妊娠失败后的经历，并呼吁为寻求堕胎的女性提供更多的医疗支持。在客厅里，警察还发现了一封特蕾莎写给昆士兰州姐姐的未完成的信。信中部分写道：“我一直很心烦，但有什么用呢？我现在已经两个半月了，看来这次我是躲不掉了。我们本来打算今年圣诞节回家的，但现在去不了了，因为我预产期在1月底。所以宝宝现在得小心了。”信中还提出了一个问题：“你为什么要停药？”似乎是指避孕药。目前尚不清楚这个问题是针对特蕾莎的姐姐，还是她对自己提出的反问。无论如何，再加上
own pregnancy and called for greater medical support for women seeking abortions. In the lounge room, police also found a half-finished letter that Theresa had written to her sister in Queensland. It read in part, I have been so upset, but what's the use? I'm two and a half months now, so it looks like I've had it this time. We were going to come up home this Christmas but won't be able to now as I'll be due the end of January. So Bub will have to be careful now." The letter also featured the question, why did you go off the pill, seemingly referring to the contraceptive pill. It was unclear if the question was directed towards Theresa's sister or was a rhetorical question for herself. Either way, coupled with
关于堕胎的文章，这让警方怀疑特蕾莎对怀孕的喜悦程度可能并不像她让邻居们相信的那样。当再次被问及时，克劳福德家的一位邻居说，特蕾莎曾向她吐露，她在生下最小的女儿后患有产后抑郁症，并为此需要药物治疗。警方想知道特蕾莎的怀孕是否与谋杀案有关。特蕾莎是一位虔诚的天主教徒。也许埃尔默一直在逼她堕胎，但她拒绝了。撇开猜测不谈，埃尔默·克劳福德的意图仍然是一个谜。唯一可以确定的是
the article about abortion, it led police to suspect that Theresa might not have been as happy about her pregnancy as she'd led her neighbours to believe. When questioned again, one of the Crawford's neighbours said that Theresa had confided in her that she'd suffered from postnatal depression after the birth of her youngest daughter, for which she'd required medication. Police wondered whether Theresa's pregnancy could have something to do with the murders. Theresa was a dedicated Catholic. Perhaps Elmer had been pushing her to have an abortion, but she'd refused. Speculation aside, Elmer Crawford's intent remained a mystery. The only thing for certain
这是一次蓄意且精心策划的袭击。埃尔默不仅花时间精心安排了他的车，而且看起来他还亲自制作了用于电击特蕾莎、凯瑟琳和詹姆斯的鳄鱼夹装置。家用保险丝的设计是在电流激增时熔断。对克劳福德家保险丝盒的检查显示，普通的保险丝已被粗电线取代，以防止它们在电流激增时熔断。现有证据表明，埃尔默很可能计划在离开去开始新生活之前，制造他家人失踪的假象。
was that this had been a deliberate and carefully planned attack. Not only had Ulmar taken the time to painstakingly organise his car, it also appeared that he'd personally made the alligator clip device that had been used to electrocute Theresa, Catherine and James. Household fuses are designed to blow during a surge of current. An examination of the Crawford's fuse box showed that the regular fuses had been replaced with thick wire to prevent them from blowing during a surge. The available evidence indicated Elmar likely planned to stage his family's disappearance before going off to start a new life.
制造他家人失踪的假象，然后离开去开始新生活。也许他打算告诉人们，特蕾莎和孩子们搬到了昆士兰州，以便在迎接新宝宝时离她的家人更近，而他则留下来把房子挂牌出售。如果车子按计划掉进水里，埃尔默本可以悄悄卖掉一切，拿走他的钱，然后毫无疑问地消失。篝火、给送奶工的信以及去垃圾场的次数，无疑表明他正准备永远离开这个家。侦探们还怀疑，从排气管通向驾驶员车窗的软管是一个计谋，以防车子从
stage his family's disappearance before going off to start a new life. Perhaps he intended to tell people that Theresa and the children had moved to Queensland to be closer to her family for the arrival of the new baby while he stayed behind to put the house on the market. If the car had gone into the water as planned, Elmar could have quietly sold up everything, taken his money, and disappeared without question. The bonfires, letter to the milkman, and visits to the tip certainly suggested he was getting ready to leave the house for good. Detectives also wondered if the hose leading from the exhaust pipe to the driver's window was a ploy in case the car was ever recovered from the
海底被捞出来。也许埃尔默的计划是让它看起来像是特蕾莎在谋杀后自杀，杀死了孩子们。这也可能解释为什么特蕾莎的头部伤势比其他人轻。也许埃尔默曾希望她的骨骼遗骸不会显示出任何颅骨骨折。随着特蕾莎·克劳福德及其孩子们的尸体被发现后的几周过去，没有出现任何证据表明埃尔默·克劳福德可能在哪里。然而，有证据表明他已经为逃亡生活做好了准备。克劳福德家的邻居们都知道，埃尔默把很多业余时间都花在当地的拍卖行。他喜欢带去一些物品，如工具、衣服和电器，
bottom of the ocean. Perhaps Elma's plan was to make it look like Theresa had killed the children in a murder-suicide. This could also explain why Theresa's head injury was less severe than the others. Maybe Elma had hoped that her skeletal remains wouldn't show any skull fractures. As the weeks passed after the bodies of Theresa Crawford and her children were found, not a single piece of evidence emerged to suggest where Elmer Crawford could be. Yet, evidence emerged to suggest that he was prepared for a life on the run. It was well known to the Crawfords' neighbours that Elmer spent a lot of his spare time at the local auction rooms. He liked to take items in such as tools, clothing, and electrical gear,
他会把这些东西留给潜在的买家。他稍后会回来收取任何收益以及任何未售出的物品。他把这么多时间花在这个爱好上，以至于当邻居问特蕾莎埃尔默在哪里时，她通常会翻个白眼说：“他又在拍卖行了。”埃尔默在休假期间曾两次去过拍卖行。他留下了一系列物品，包括25码长的电线、一卷电线、一盒电池夹、一把铲子、一把鹤嘴锄、两把大锤和几加仑机油。他在6月底回来收取销售所得，总共26美元，大约相当于今天的350美元。
which he'd leave for potential buyers. He'd return later to collect any proceeds as well as any of his unsold items. He spent so much time on this hobby that when neighbours asked Theresa where Elmer was, she would typically roll her eyes and say, He's at the auction houses again. Elmer had made two visits to an auction house during his time off work. He'd left an assortment of items, including 25 yards of electrical leads, a coil of wire, a box of battery clips, a spade, a matic, two sledgehammers, and several gallons of motor oil. He returned at the end of June to collect the money from his sales, $26 in total, or roughly $350 in today's money.
对于调查人员来说，这解释了克劳福德一家为何如此富裕。他们发现，一些拍卖商最近开始怀疑埃尔默带来的是赃物，并停止接受他的生意。事实证明，埃尔默一直在从工作中窃取铜线，然后卖给废金属商。在克劳福德家的车库和屋顶内，警察发现了一个小型的货物仓库，这些货物可以追溯到维多利亚州赛马委员会，包括从电器到卷筒卫生纸的所有东西。虽然埃尔默的银行账户自他失踪后就没被动过，
For the investigators, this explained how the Crawfords were so well off. They discovered that some of the auctioneers had recently grown suspicious that Ulmer was bringing in stolen goods and they'd stopped accepting his business. It also turned out that Elmer had been stealing copper wiring from work which he then sold to scrap metal merchants. In the Crawfords' garage and inside their roof, police found a small warehouse of goods that could be attributed back to the Victorian Racing Commission, including everything from electrical items to rolls of toilet paper. Although Elmer's bank accounts hadn't been touched since he disappeared,
考虑到他有出售赃物的嗜好，他很有可能一直在囤积现金，并随身带走了大量现金。作为一名电工，也意味着他在旅行途中可以打零工赚取现金。到目前为止，埃尔默的照片已在澳大利亚全国范围内广泛传播，但没有任何地方有关于他的目击报告。考虑到埃尔默与爱尔兰的联系以及他在加拿大的家人，警方曾向海外当局进行过查询，但没有结果。警方曾向海外当局进行过查询，但没有结果。在克劳福德一家谋杀案发生一周年之际，警方在寻找任何答案方面没有任何进展。1971年7月举行了死因裁判官调查，期间裁判官询问首席凶杀案侦探，他是否认为埃尔默·克劳福德应对杀害特蕾莎·克劳福德和三个孩子负责。侦探不置可否，说：“我认为这不是我的职责，先生，
given his proclivity for selling stolen items, it was possible that he'd been hoarding cash and had taken a large amount with him. Being an electrician also meant he could have picked up cash in hand work along his travels. By now photos of Elmer had been widely circulated Australia-wide and there had been no reported sightings of him anywhere. Given Elmer's Irish connection and his family in Canada, inquiries were made with authorities overseas, but to no result. Inquiries were made with authorities overseas, but to no result. By the one year anniversary of the Crawford family murders, police were no closer to finding any answers. A coronial inquest was held in July 1971, during which the coroner asked the lead homicide detective if he thought Elmer Crawford was responsible for killing Theresa Crawford and the three children. The detective was non-committal saying, I don't think that is my function sir, it
这是法院的职责。”裁判官重新措辞了问题，这次问道：“你们的调查是否发现了任何其他可能杀害这些人的类似人员？”侦探回答说：“没有，先生，没有发现。”裁判官认定埃尔默·克劳福德应对杀害其妻子和三个孩子负责，但这并没有让调查更接近于查明埃尔默本人发生了什么。1973年1月下旬，在调查结束一年半后，流动工人彼得·卡尔森（Peter Carlson）在维多利亚州地区城市谢珀顿（Shepparton）的一家就业办公室排队时，与一个名叫哈里（Harry）的男人攀谈起来。哈里告诉彼得，他目前
is the function of the court. The coroner rephrased the question, this time asking, have your inquiries revealed any other like person who could have killed these people? The detective replied, no sir, they haven't. The coroner found Elmer Crawford responsible for killing his wife and three children, but this didn't bring the investigation any closer to finding out what happened to Elmer himself. In late January 1973, a year and a half after the inquest, itinerant worker Peter Carlson was standing in line at an employment office in the regional Victorian city of Shepparton when he struck up a conversation with a man named Harry. Harry told Peter he was currently
正在与妻子办理离婚。两人听说在距离约70公里的河地小镇科布拉姆（Cobram）的一个果园里有一些采摘水果的工作。他们和其他两个男人一起跳上一辆出租车，直接前往那里开始工作，其中包括在物业内的住宿。1月29日星期一晚上，彼得、哈里和另一名工人前往科布拉姆酒店。他们打车回果园，但在旅途中与司机发生了争执。警察被叫来，三名水果采摘工被带到当地警察局。哈里不久后被释放，而另外两人被拘留过夜。晚上11点30分，哈里的尸体在科布拉姆南路（Cobram South Road）路边被发现，
going through a divorce from his wife. The two men heard there was some fruit picking work available on an orchard in Cobram, a riverland town approximately 70 kilometres away. Along with two other men, they jumped into a cab and headed straight there to begin work, which included accommodation on the property. On the evening of Monday January 29, Peter, Harry and one of the other workers headed to the Cobram Hotel. They caught a cab back to the orchard, but along the journey they got into an argument with the driver. The police were called and the three fruit pickers were taken to the local police station. Harry was released shortly after while the other two were kept overnight. At 11.30pm, Harry's body was found on the side of Cobram South Road,
显然是在一起道路事故中丧生。赶到现场的警察看了一眼哈里，立刻从他几年前看过的照片中认出了他。他看起来就像埃尔默·克劳福德。这名男子身上没有任何身份证明或金钱，但正如警方很快了解到的那样，他一直以哈里·克劳福德的名字生活。死者的指纹和牙科记录被提取出来，以确定是否能进行正面识别，警方发言人告诉媒体，
having been killed in an apparent road accident. The police officer who attended the scene took one look at Harry and immediately recognised him from photographs he'd seen years prior. He looked just like Elmer Crawford. The man was carrying no form of identification or money, but as the police soon learned he'd been going by the name Harry Crawford. The deceased man's fingerprints and dental records were taken to see if a positive identification could be made, with a police spokesperson telling the media,
“如果他是埃尔默·克劳福德，我们将解开维多利亚州警察局历史上最令人困惑的谜团之一。”结果出来了。他不是埃尔默·克劳福德。随着岁月的流逝，关于埃尔默的未经证实的目击事件和故事零星出现，包括他在爱尔兰担任爱尔兰共和军的杀手。大多数目击事件似乎要么是认错人，要么仅仅是谣言。然后，在1994年，一位曾经从埃尔默·克劳福德那里购买铜线的废品商的妻子正在访问西澳大利亚州的班伯里市（Bunbury），距离格伦罗伊约3300公里。
if it is Elmer Crawford, we will clear up one of the most baffling mysteries in the history of the Victoria Police Force. The results came back. It wasn't Elmer Crawford. As the years went by, unsubstantiated sightings and stories about Elmer trickled in, including that he was in Ireland working as a hitman for the Irish Republican Army. Most of the sightings seemed to be either cases of mistaken identity or just rumours. Then, in 1994, the wife of one of the scrap dealers who used to buy copper wire from Elmer Crawford was visiting the Western Australian city of Bunbury, some 3,300 kilometres west of Glenroy.
她在当地一家酒店时，看到了一个她认为是那名被指控的家庭灭门凶手的人。这位女士走近那个男人，问他是否是埃尔默·克劳福德。他说不是，他只是从新西兰来旅游的。当这位女士向警方报告这次相遇时，已经过去了两个星期。警方没有找到班伯里男子的踪迹，但他们认为这次目击可能是真实的。在20世纪70年代，西澳大利亚州人口稀少，更偏远的地区以成为想要消失的人的避风港而闻名。当时电子设备的使用非常有限，无法追踪一个人的行踪，甚至不需要身份证件就可以开设银行账户。鉴于
She was at a local hotel when she saw a man she believed to be the accused family annihilator. The woman approached the man and asked if he was Elmer Crawford. He said no, he was just visiting from New Zealand. By the time the woman reported this encounter to the police, two weeks had passed. Police found no trace of the Bumbary man, but they believed the sighting could be genuine. In the 1970s, Western Australia was sparsely populated and the more remote parts were renowned for being safe havens for people wanting to vanish. There was very limited use of electronics that could track a person's movements and you didn't even need an ID to open a bank account. Given
埃尔默的电工技能，他很有可能在某个偏远的矿区找到了工作，并从此设法避开了雷达。如果班伯里的目击事件是真实的，那么这位女士没有更早报告，意味着埃尔默有充足的时间再次消失。直到21世纪初，当一具身份不明的男性尸体出现在德克萨斯州的一家停尸房时，才出现了其他可信的线索。死者为了隐藏身份费尽了心思。他的指纹受损，并持有至少四个不同名字的虚假身份证件。
Elmer's electrician skills, it was possible that he'd secured work in one of the remote mining sites and had managed to fly under the radar since. If the Bumbary sighting had been genuine, the woman's failure to report it sooner meant Elmer had plenty of time to disappear again. There were no other credible leads until the early 2000s when an unidentified male body appeared in a Texas morgue. The deceased had gone to great lengths to hide his identity. His fingerprints were damaged and he had false identity documents with at least four different names.
这名男子身份不明地躺了五年，直到面部识别软件标记他与年长的埃尔默·克劳福德长相高度相似。埃尔默的一位在世血亲提供了他们的DNA进行比对。但就在澳大利亚警方思考这名逃犯是如何到达美国时，DNA测试显示这名身份不明的男子不是埃尔默。到2008年初，克劳福德一家谋杀案已经过去了37年，如果埃尔默还活着，他将是78岁。维多利亚州警方宣布了10万美元的悬赏，他们希望这能提供一种激励，鼓励任何可能知道埃尔默·克劳福德下落的人挺身而出。他们还发布了一张年龄增强图像，展示了如果埃尔默还
The man lay unidentified for five years until facial recognition software flagged him as bearing a strong resemblance to an older Elmer Crawford. A living blood relative of Elmer provided their DNA for comparison. But just as Australian police were contemplating how the fugitive could have gotten himself to the US, DNA testing revealed that the unidentified man was not Elmer. By early 2008, 37 years had passed since the Crawford family murders and if Elmer was still alive he would have been 78 years old. Victoria Police announced a $100,000 reward which they hoped might provide an incentive to encourage anybody who may know of Elmer Crawford's whereabouts to come forward. They also released an age-enhanced image of what Elmer might look like if he was still
活着可能的样子。警方承诺向任何提供有关他下落信息的人提供免于起诉的保证。一位侦探说：“……多年来有许多关于埃尔默的目击报告，这使我们相信他还活着，并居住在州际以逃避侦查。他很可能为了掩盖身份而改变了外貌。他以前是一名无证电工，即使现在已到退休年龄，他仍有可能在私下做一些这类工作。特蕾莎、凯瑟琳、詹姆斯和凯伦理应得到一些答案，我们相信外面有人掌握着能将责任人绳之以法的信息。”2017年，一位前卡车
alive. Indemnity from prosecution was promised to anyone who provided information regarding his whereabouts. One detective said, "...there have been a number of sightings of Velmar over the years, which leads us to believe that he is still alive and living interstate to avoid detection. It is likely that he has changed his appearance in order to disguise his identity. He previously worked as an unqualified electrician and even though would now be of retirement age, it is possible he still does a bit of this type of work on the side. Theresa, Catherine, James and Karen deserve some answers, and we believe somebody out there has information that will bring those people responsible to justice. In 2017, a former truck
司机，化名“Nugget”，挺身而出报告了在西澳大利亚州偏远的皮尔巴拉（Pilbara）地区可能目击到埃尔默·克劳福德的情况。据Nugget说，他与一个男人攀谈起来，那人说他是在1970年从墨尔本搬到该地区的。Nugget问那个男人他的妻子在哪里，他回答说她早就走了。Nugget接着问那个男人为什么要离开墨尔本。那人回答说：“我必须匆忙离开。我做了一件可怕的事。”侦探们最近刚去过西澳大利亚州，跟进另一份关于埃尔默·克劳福德的目击报告。就在那时，Nugget灵光一现。“你不是维多利亚州的警察前几天在这里
driver who went by the name Nugget came forward to report a possible sighting of Elmacrawford in the remote Pilbara region of Western Australia. According to Nugget, he struck up a conversation with a man who said he'd moved to the area from Melbourne in 1970. Nugget asked the man where his wife was, to which he responded that she was long gone. Nugget then asked the man why he'd left Melbourne. The man responded, I had to leave in a hurry. I did something terrible. Detectives had recently been to Western Australia following up on another reported sighting of Elma Crawford. It was then that Nugget had a light bulb moment. You aren't that bloke the Victorian coppers were up here
寻找的那个家伙吗？”他问道。据Nugget说，那个男人的肢体语言完全变了。看起来他意识到自己说得太多了。真实犯罪作家格雷格·福加蒂（Greg Fogarty）在格伦罗伊的红衣主教路长大。克劳福德谋杀案发生时他九岁，完全意识到这个家庭所遭受的悲剧。成长过程中，格雷格和他的朋友们认为老克劳福德家闹鬼。他成年后仍然对这个案件着迷，将其臭名昭著的程度比作1966年三名博蒙特（Beaumont）儿童的失踪案，正如Casefile第100集所报道的那样。格雷格
looking for a couple of weeks ago, he asked. According to Nugget, the man's body language completely changed. It looked like he realised he'd said too much. True crime author Greg Fogarty grew up in Cardinal Road, Glenroy. He was nine years old at the time of the Crawford murders and fully aware of the tragedy that had befallen the family. Growing up, Greg and his friends regarded the old Crawford house as haunted. He remained fascinated by the case into adulthood, likening its infamy to the 1966 disappearance of the three Beaumont children, as covered in episode 100 of Case File. Greg
感到有必要进一步调查克劳福德案，并最终写了一本关于它的书，名为《近乎完美》（Almost Perfect）。在研究和撰写这本书的三年的时间里，格雷格在报纸上刊登广告，要求任何了解克劳福德一家情况的人联系他。几个人挺身而出，包括一位从未向警方提供过陈述的前邻居。虽然所有其他邻居都形容埃尔默友好且温和，但这位邻居声称他们曾看到埃尔默在修理汽车时陷入狂怒。因为对自己正在做的事情不起作用而感到沮丧，埃尔默用轮胎撬棍砸碎了汽车的每一块面板。多年来，格雷格听到了许多关于埃尔默·克劳福德可能在哪里的故事。
felt compelled to look into the Crawford case further, and ultimately wrote a book about it, titled Almost Perfect. Over the three years it took to research and write the book, Greg put ads in the newspapers asking anyone who knew anything about the Crawfords to contact him. Several people came forward, including one former neighbour who had never given a statement to police. While all other neighbours had described Elmer as friendly and placid, this neighbour claimed they once saw Elmer fly into a fit of rage while trying to fix his car. Frustrated that whatever he was doing wasn't working, Elmer smashed every panel of the car with a tyre iron. Over the years, Greg heard many stories about where Elmer Crawford could be.
1970年，澳大利亚人无需证件即可前往新西兰。埃尔默可能在从那里继续前往其他地方之前去了新西兰。他可能被爱尔兰的家人或其他支持者收留。虽然没有埃尔默出国旅行的记录，但这并不排除他使用假名旅行的可能性。一个名叫艾伦（Alan）的男人也联系了格雷格，说他认识一个在西澳大利亚州当电工的男人，长得和埃尔默·克劳福德一模一样。这个男人说话带有爱尔兰口音，在被问及过去时闪烁其词。艾伦非常确信那个男人就是埃尔默，于是他给格雷格发了一张照片。
In 1970, Australians could travel to New Zealand without documentation. Elmer could have travelled to New Zealand before continuing onwards from there. He might have been harboured by family members or other supporters in Ireland. While there are no records of Elmer travelling overseas, it doesn't rule out the possibility that he was travelling under a false name. A man named Alan also reached out to Greg saying he knew a man that worked as an electrician in Western Australia who looked just like Elmer Crawford. This man spoke with an Irish accent and was cagey when questioned about his past. Alan was so convinced that the man was Elmer that he sent Greg a photo.
格雷格分析了这张照片，但在将其与埃尔默的照片进行比较时，耳朵的形状并不相同。如果他还活着，埃尔默·克劳福德现在已经95岁了。10万美元的悬赏仍然有效。任何有信息的人都被敦促联系灭罪热线（Crimestoppers）。凶杀案侦探最近表示，他们并没有放弃希望，这个长达五十年的悬案总有一天会得到解决。随着围绕此案的所有谜团以及对埃尔默的关注，关于特蕾莎、凯瑟琳、詹姆斯和凯伦的公开报道很少。那些最了解他们的人，比如凯瑟琳的朋友布伦达，对他们悲剧发生前的生活记忆犹新。她是埃尔默失踪前最后一个与他交谈的人。谋杀案发生后，布伦达每天上学时，都会假装凯瑟琳就在她身边。2005年，
Greg had the photo analysed, but when comparing it to pictures of Elmer, the years were not the same shape. If he is still alive, Elmer Crawford would now be 95 years old. The $100,000 reward still stands. Anyone with information is urged to contact Crimestoppers. Homicide detectives recently stated that they have not given up hope that the five decade long cold case might be solved one day. With all the mystery surrounding the case and the focus put on Elmer, very little has been reported publicly about Theresa, Catherine, James and Karen. Memories of their lives before the tragedy are held close by those who knew them best, like Catherine's friend, Brenda. She was the last person to speak to Elmer prior to his disappearance. Every day that Brenda walked to school following the murders, she pretended that Catherine was by her side. In 2005,
布伦达接受了《时代报》的首次采访，她说每次开车经过红衣主教路上的旧房子时，她仍然会想到凯瑟琳、她的母亲和兄弟姐妹。布伦达说：“我经常想，如果她还活着，她现在会做什么，她的生活会是什么样子。”2011年，一场悲剧在澳大利亚墨尔本一条安静的郊区小溪边上演。溪里有一具穿着粉红色睡袍的年轻成年女性尸体。他以为她只是脱掉了长袍，把它扔进了水里。但他不知道那实际上是一具毫无生气的尸体。警方很快排除了任何可疑情况，而其他人则不太确定。路易丝（Louise）是一个非常、非常好的游泳者。我们去过海滩，去过游泳池。
Brenda gave her first ever interview to the Age newspaper saying that she still thought of Catherine, her mother and siblings every time she drove past their old house on Cardinal Road. Brenda said, I often wonder what she'd be doing now, how her life would have been had she lived. In 2011, a tragedy unfolded along the banks of a quiet suburban creek in Melbourne, Australia. In the creek was the body of a young adult female clad in a pink dressing gown. He assumed that she just threw her robe off and just threw it in the water. But little did he know that that was actually a lifeless body. Police were quick to rule out any suspicious circumstances, while others weren't so sure. Louise was a very, very good swimmer. We'd gone to the beach, we'd gone to the pools.
你不能只看一具尸体就说，哦，他们淹死了或者没有淹死。这取决于具体情况。她的死是你从未听说过的案件，但她的一生是你永远不会忘记的故事。我一直盯着时间，妈妈。去那里要小心，因为有一天，你知道，你可能会决定不想回来了。或者因为生活条件，他只会给她食物，就像她是囚犯一样。
You cannot just look at a body and say, oh they drowned or no they didn't drown. It's based on the circumstances. Her death is a case you've never heard of before, but her life is a story you'll never forget. I kept the time on my listen mum. Be careful going there, because one day, you know, you might decide to not want to come back. Or for living conditions, and he would just give her food like she was a prisoner.
他们虽然是大块头，看起来很凶，但他们想帮助她。随着对她死亡的新调查开始，惊人的启示浮出水面。我从墨尔本机场接了一位女性，她很沮丧，在哭泣。现在看看她的肺，她的肺，啊哈！我这辈子从来没有给任何人打过电话并提供毒品。这荒谬吗？这就像是说这个案件与溺水一致。这不是爱，也不是善良或尊重。
They were big tough guys though, they looked really mean but they wanted to help her. As a fresh investigation into her death begins startling revelations come to light. I collected a female from the Melbourne airport, she was upset and crying. Looking at her lungs right now and her lungs, aha! Never once in my life have I ever rang anyone and offered them drugs. Is that ridiculous? It is like to say that this case is consistent with drowning. This is not love or kindness or respect.
我们抓住你了。我是朱莉娅·罗布森（Julia Robson），这是《困水》（Troubled Waters），由Casefile Presents制作。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
We've got you. I'm Julia Robson and this is Troubled Waters, a Case File Presents production. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们为您准备好了。我是朱莉娅·罗布森，这是《困水》，由Case File Presents制作。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。